So there are a number of other
monetization methods out there and
I brought a list of them,
just because there's a huge number and
I want to make sure that I'm
not leaving important ones out.
I left this to the end because
the performance is really going to vary
app to app, where some of the other
monetization methods that we went
over are a little bit more common.
Firstly, there are surveys.
This is where you're offering
players in game rewards.
Generally for
branded surveys, what's your favorite
soft drink, things like that.
There are also real world rewards.
So this is the most popular case for
this would be if somebody maybe gets
level four in whatever your game is and
they get a reward for free Kleenexes or
something like that that they can
them redeem at a real world location or
order to their house.
There's also Affiliate or Ecommerce.
So I've seen with a lot of cases,
particularly games and apps that
are extremely well designed or arted,
that sometimes they'll sell prints
of popular characters or
other elements directly to players.
In some cases they'll direct them to
other App Stores and thinks like that,
that they can purchase this.
And in a lot of cases you can
get affiliate revenue which is
a percentage of the users purchase.
Even if they're not purchasing whatever
you're directing them to, which is key.
So if you send them to the App Store and
within 24 hours they make a purchase
of another game, you'll get
a very small percentage of that.
If you have a wide enough audience base,
this adds up which is really cool.
There are also things
like notification ads,
little pop-up notifications, text ads.
There are things such as
offer walls that were for
I guess, like the beginning of
the App Store, extremely popular.
And that's where you're offering
players the ability again,
to get in game rewards, if they either
download and install other games or
if they complete offers for
subscriptions to magazines or Netflix or
something like that which
is extremely popular.
Finally, there are app walls which
is like a hybrid of offer wall and
banner ad unit, where you display
a list of different games or apps.
Perhaps some of them you own,
some of them you don't own, and
players can pick and
choose what they want to download.
There's a whole range here and
it really depends on what
converts best within your game.